how's it feel to be here together but
also to be recognized by GLAAD in this
way it's a little bittersweet but we're
so excited to be back together and to
see each other again and to be
recognized for the work of this amazing
people are doing and writing and we're
excited and hopeful I was gonna say I'm
I'm feeling angry about it and I know a
lot of fans are that one that your show
was cancelled but they've been really
rallying for networks to really pick it
up what has that meant to you guys to
see that kind of response from your fans
oh my gosh well schoesser cancels
everyday and nobody cares so we're aware
of that so we're so grateful to our
community and I think it really speaks
to this moment in time where we are
speaking for so many communities that
are demonized that they're not getting
enough love and we are showing them we
are showing an LGBTQ teen we are showing
a veteran mother we are showing a lot
next family with love and warmth and
goodness these are proud Americans that
are a vibrant part of our society and
great humor not at the expense of who
they are right and where they come from
what are the chances that it will get
picked up somewhere have you guys been
in talk we're feeling optimistic I mean
how could we not with the kind of
attention that you know the population
has has given us and and you know
there's there's a rabid fan base out
there and and they want to see the
Alvarez family continues so I think the
networks will see that and I think in
time we'll all know
are you keeping in touch with your
fellow cast members oh my god what do we
not talk to each other
this is flying if you're like a girl
group hug yeah Marco Polo we follow each
other yeah I copy onto that and we do
have a group text we also like reply to
each other's Instagram stories on the
time we know this is a family forever
yeah his Rita Moreno just sending gifts
and emojis in this text she is too busy
being fabulous emoji like texts are
funny check she became a peacock today
body yes legend Peabody Award three her
Barbra Streisand and I can't remember
who the other she's a great company and
so well-deserved I mean can you believe
II that share the screen with her could
I believe that I shared the screen with
her no and but also yes because she
never made you feel like she is the
legend that she is so in theory I'm
always like oh my god I work for the
Niigata and then I get said I'm like
snapper eat up there I see you later
that's awesome yeah it was even better
yeah well you guys congratulations I'm
hopeful for you guys as well but enjoy
tonight
[Music]